[Música]
tengo que confesaros una cosa
me llamo manuel enciso y soy adicto a
los datos
pero que no cunda el pánico porque eso
no es un problema para nosotros ni para
mí
no es un problema para vosotros porque
no es contagioso no os voy a pegar nada
y no es un problema para mí porque a mí
no me limita
a mí me das superpoderes
no veo muy convencido
claro porque no sabéis que debajo llevo
el traje de super datos
si no es muy comercial super ratón
esto le funcionaba mucho a karting
claro que claro y yo no teníamos el
mismo cuerpo así que yo voy a utilizar
y otras armas yo también tengo mis armas
y la voy a poner en práctica aquí
concretamente el método científico
voy a describir los superpoderes que
tengo y luego voy a hacer un experimento
en vivo en directo
tengo dos superpoderes a falta de uno
el primer superpoder es que soy capaz de
ver la realidad tal cual es diáfana
no parece muy interesante pasaros por
twitter y me decir luego si eso es
importante
y el segundo es que no solo se acaba de
ver la realidad ahora sino que soy capaz
de ver el futuro
los que tenemos estos superpoderes que
tenemos nuestra reunión fija
hablamos del primer superpoder cómo
interpretar los datos y del segundo como
estimar pronosticar pero no deje engañar
ver la realidad y ver el futuro así
vamos a hacer el experimento he recogido
los datos de una sesión que de ex
anterior y os puedo enseñar algunas
cosas muy interesantes
779 personas fueron a esta sesión
nos parece muy interesante
me voy a forzar un poquito más lo paso
por el filtro de la igualdad de género
y ahora la paridad se sacan conclusiones
interesantes respecto a los asistentes
tampoco muy convencidos claro por qué
porque si miráis a la izquierda y la
derecha esa conclusión la podéis sacar
vosotros reconocer fácilmente quién es
hombre quién es mujer y más o menos
tenéis esa conclusión voy a irme algo
que no es tan fácil descubrir la edad
bueno si miramos la distribución de las
edades queda algo así es una
distribución normal parece ajustarse a
la distribución normal no es una
distribución normal y corriente es que
se llama 6 de instrucción normal donde
en el centro están los valores más
frecuentes y los raritos son los
extremos
y eso está muy bien porque tiene en fin
unas propiedades muy interesantes que
gustan mucho en la matemática
pero a mí lo que me gusta más es lo que
no se ve
hay gente que cuando rellena la ficha no
declara su edad vamos a llamarle a eso
derecho a la coquetería
hay mucha gente que ejerce su derecho a
la coquetería y me he preocupado de
mirar si es más frecuente en fin tenemos
eso son pocos muy poquitos los que no
ejercen el derecho a la coquetería en
ese diagrama de barras se expresa creo
que bastante bien pero voy a expresarlo
con un diagrama de tartas porque y ahora
sí creo que os puede terminar de
convencer voy a sacar una conclusión que
quizá no esperábamos antes de llegar
aquí y eso es lo bonito de los batos
son más coquetos los hombres sí señor
sí
en realidad voy a hacer un paréntesis
porque he utilizado
diagramas para expresar y comunicar la
información de los datos esto antes era
muy complicado antes de que se hiciera
esto que se llama visualización de los
datos había que hacer un matrix y
entonces había que señalar y yo tenía
que irme para allá y señalar la fila y
la columna y con un puntero láser
indicarnos exactamente el dato que
quería que viera el grano ni mucho menos
ahora comunicó una idea a todo el
auditorio y vosotros acá en la
conclusión al instante
yo no sé si esto es un superpoder pero
que los políticos me compran esta mañana
seguro seguro
bueno pues no es un superpoder esto
nosotros sí pero esto no porque porque
el mérito no es mío
el mérito es vuestro o tampoco el
vuestro
el mérito es de vuestro cerebro y de los
millones de años de evolución común que
recoge rápidamente los colores las
formas los tamaños los comparas y saca
la conclusión así al instante
está bien
pero desde el nacimiento de spiderman
sabemos que un gran poder conlleva una
gran responsabilidad
y entonces podemos poner estos poderes
al servicio al bien y seremos
superhéroes o podemos ponerlo al
servicio del mal y seremos súper
villanos
los supervillanos no quieren acabar con
la humanidad en este caso no preocuparon
pero quieren engañarnos confundirnos y
manipularlos
voy a poner algunos ejemplos traídos del
mundo real para ilustrar esto el primer
ejemplo lo ha traído del mundo de la
política
ya había gente crispada del ambiente no
anonimizar he respetado escrupulosamente
las formas los colores los tamaños de la
presentación original pero he analizado
los dos partidos políticos que van a
aparecer ahí en más los retratos de los
líderes políticos los seis sustituidos
en fin me he permitido eso por dos
personas que tuvieron una rivalidad en
su época por un fin mucho más noble las
formas no fueron luego tan nobles pero
al fin si quiere ser el mejor científico
en su época así que nos encontramos a
thomas alva edison y nikola tesla
pugnando por ese galardón
en unas elecciones autonómicas
ambos líderes obtuvieron ese resultado
pobrecito thomas alva edison el debacle
electoral lo que le llegaría cuando
llegó a la sede general del partido y le
dijeron eso qué
vale veo que hay gente al final sobre
todo los de la zona que me están
diciendo que no se ve claro es que el
gráfico no quería que lo vieran
deliberadamente vamos a hacer zoom y
ahora fijaros que en fondo rojo y con la
letra azul aparecen los años en que
están toma las mediciones de 1999 a 2015
en un caso y de 2012 a 2015 los 13 años
de diferencia por favor
me voy hay la partida de teclas porque
además la televisión autonómica que
demostró esto era afín a ese partido
y ahora no parece que fuera así
es decir que el supervillano que ha
hecho esto tenía muy claro la conclusión
a la que queríamos llegar
lo que hay que tener en cuenta que no
todos los ejemplos son tan burdos como
esto a veces es algo más sutil y hay que
conocer un poquito más voy a introducir
un concepto el concepto de correlación
cerrar las puertas que no se vaya nadie
porque introducimos este concepto y si
nos desconecta y nos desconecta primero
porque estaba el ecuador de las charlas
el tiempo que habéis perdido conmigo
intentar aprovecharlo
y lo segundo y más importante es porque
todo el mundo conoce el concepto de
correlación es algo natural intuitivo sí
lo es
lo explico en lugar de medir un dato
vamos a pedir dos y lo que vamos a
estudiar y si su comportamiento
crece o decrece proporcionalmente es
decir lo que queremos estudiar si tienen
un comportamiento proporcional
ahora hay correlaciones cruzadas pero no
me voy a meter en eso es muy importante
eso porque las correlaciones nos
permiten descubrir un conocimiento nuevo
que yo luego explicó
y le doy un motivo voy a poner un
ejemplo hace tres semanas un ejemplo muy
reciente salió el estudio diciendo que
las personas que sufren obesidad se
había detectado que sus mascotas también
tienen obesidad
había una correlación muy fuerte entre
la obesidad de los dueños y de sus
mascotas bueno hay que explicar aquello
y se explicó cuando una persona es obesa
normalmente tiene hábitos de vida
sedentarios y si tienes hábitos de vida
sedentaria tu mascota ve muy poco la
calle
o sea que la sonrisa tiene también
hábitos de vida sedentario
voy a traerme un ejemplo del mundo real
en este ejemplo se miden durante 6 años
las muertes violentas en eeuu
afortunadamente se ve que ha decrecido
y en la línea roja se ve la cuota de
mercado del navegador internet explorer
os dejo a vosotros que saquéis las
conclusiones
porque yo mientras me voy a dedicar voy
a analizar un poquito más este tema que
está muy bien de la muerte violenta en
eeuu pero en tres meses en los tres
meses el calorcito parece que aprieta y
también a pintar los crímenes
y se ha medido en azul los números de
crimen crímenes violentas de muertes
violentas y en rojo
efectivamente el consumo de helados en
este mismo periodo
sí es cierto
si atendemos o intentamos extrapolar las
correlaciones para buscar la causa
efecto está clarísimo que en eeuu tienen
razón los que abogan por no controlar
las armas para reducir la criminalidad
lo que hay que reducir es el navegador
internet lores de todos los ordenadores
y el consumo de laos
ahí lo tenemos
[Aplausos]
en un ejemplo muy serio ha aparecido
este verano en un blog
se hablaba del calentamiento global
y la tendencia era ésta
estaban libres yo no sé mis compañeros
que han venido aquí a hablar de la
apocalipsis y este tipo de cosas lo veis
y claro la tendencia de la temperatura
está bajando si no está estable está
bajando
llegaron otros científicos posteriores y
dijeron un momentito primero se han
tomado las temperaturas en el mes de
agosto
y el cambio climático se mide
especialmente en los periodos fríos
segundo no se ha utilizado la media que
utilizan los meteorólogos que es un
modelo no se ha utilizado medias y
métricas porque aquí era más simple era
mejor mi ordenador no es muy potente y
tercero
veis que el registro empieza
en 1912 pero hay registros de
temperatura desde el siglo 19 pero no
interesaba porque la huella del co2 no
es tan importante y ahí si corregimos
esos tres errores aparece esto siento
comunicaros que el cambio climático
tiene esta pinta esta mala pinta
con esto espero haberos convencido de la
necesaria protección respecto a los
supervillanos que nos quieren hacer
llegar otra cosa
no queremos ser manipulados no queremos
ser confundidos no queremos ser
engañados como yo he hecho con vosotros
en esta charla dos veces al principio de
la charla primero os he dicho que los
hombres somos más concretos que las
mujeres pero fijaros que la diferencia
es muy pocas son números muy pequeñitos
pero claro cuando los números en
pequeñito una diferencia pequeña también
lleva a una gran variabilidad además del
número de hombres era mejor que el de
mujeres lo mostré pero como no lo
indique no fíjate mucho
si corrijo esas dos cosas y estudio la
proporcionalidad de los hombres
concretos sobre hombres objetos y de las
mujeres coquetas sobre mujeres en
general
y además lo que hago es mostrar
realmente
el resultado general es que los hombres
y las mujeres somos iguales también en
la coquetería y el segundo engaño es que
os he dicho que esto de los batos no se
pega lo siento estáis todos infectados
[Aplausos]